>>> AND NOW, LIVE FROM
MAR-A-LAGO, IT'S THE "FOX NEWS
UKRAINIAN INVASION CELEBRATION
SPECTACULAR!"
WITH YOUR HOSTS, TUCKER CARLSON
AND LAURA INGRAHAM!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HI.
>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M TUCKER CARLSON.
I'M LIKE A PAIR OF BOAT SHOES
CAME TO LIFE.
>> AND I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
AND WHEN I WATCH "HARRY POTTER"
I ROOT FOR VOLDEMORT.
>> WE GOT INTO A LITTLE BIT OF
TROUBLE FOR ALL THE NICE THINGS
WE SAID ABOUT RUSSIA AND THE
MEAN THING WE SAID ABOUT
UKRAINE.
>> WE DID SOUND PRETTY AWFUL IN
HINDSIGHT.
AND FORESIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I KEPT ASKING WHY DO WE HATE
PUTIN?
AREN'T LIBERALS IN AMERICA EVEN
WORSE?
>> AND I CALLED THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE PATHETIC.
HE STAYED AND FOUGHT WITH HIS
PEOPLE IN THE WAR AND I CALLED
HIM PATHETIC FROM A NEWS DESK IN
WASHINGTON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I KEPT SAYING WE SHOULD BE
MORE WORRIED ABOUT OUR OWN
BORDER GETTING INVADED BY
MEXICO.
BUT IN MY DEFENSE, I AM RACIST.
SO I THOUGHT THAT WAS TRUE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BUT TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE IT UP OW.
WE'RE RAISING MONEY FOR THE REAL
VICTIMS OF THIS INVASION.
THE OLIGARCHS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BECAUSE WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THE BABIES.
THEIR SUGAR BABIES.
WHO WILL POUR VODKA IN THEIR
MOUTHS?
SO MANY HORNY MOUTHS TO FEED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO PLEASE OPEN YOUR WALLETS
AND BECAUSE THIS IS FOX NEWS YOU
CAN EITHER SEND MONEY OR TAKE
OUT A REVERSE MORTGAGE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO FAR WE'VE RAISED OVER 8.3
BILLION RUBLES, WHICH COMES OUT
TO ALMOST $12.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND THIS IS INCREDIBLY
EXCITING.
FORMER AND CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES DONALD TRUMP
IS MANNING THE PHONE LINES
HIMSELF.
>> AND THE THING IS ABOUT
RIHANNA, SHE CAN PULL IT OFF.
SHE CAN BE NINE MONTHS.
THE BODY'S STILL INCREDIBLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT NOW YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LOT OF WOMEN WEEK, SEEING THIS
RIGHT NOW, 3s, 4s, FRANKLY
TROLLS, WEARING THE SAME
SEE-THROUGH SHIRT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I HESITATE TO SAY WHALES BECAUSE
I KNOW THE WHALES, I'M VERY
POPULAR WITH THE WHALES.
I DO GREAT WITH WHALES.
THEY COME UP TO ME ON THE BEACH
AND THEY SAY THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, THE BLOWHOLES BLASTING
AWAY.
200, 300 FEET IN THE AIR.
IT'S HOW THEY SALUTE ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
WE'LL COME BACK TO YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE OUR FIRST
GUEST IS HERE.
HE'S A GREAT AMERICAN PATRIOT.
SO GREAT THAT HE LEFT AMERICA
AND BECAME A RUSSIAN CITIZEN.
THE PUFFIEST ACTION STAR IN THE
WORLD, STEVEN SEAGAL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, TUCKER.
OH, WHAT A GLOBAL CRISIS WE ARE
FACING.
AS SOMEONE WHO PROUDLY PRETENDS
TO BE BOTH NATIVE AMERICAN AND
JAPANESE, I FEEL FOR ALL PEOPLE.
>> NOW, YOU'RE CLOSE WITH
PRESIDENT PUTIN, RIGHT?
>> YES.
PUTIN AND I ARE, AS THEY SAY IN
ANCIENT JAPAN, ESKIMO BROTHERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO I WILL BE HONORING PUTIN BY
PERFORMING AN AUTHENTIC
TAEKWONDO EXHIBITION.
HA-YA.
EE-YO.
NOW IT'S TIME TO HONOR MYSELF
WITH A TRADITIONAL JAPANESE
SHAMROCK SHAKE.
THE TRADITIONAL SEASONAL
BEVERAGE OF ALL AIKIDO
EXHIBITIONS.
HA-YA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LET'S CHECK BACK IN WITH THE
MAN WHO SAID PUTIN'S INVASION
WAS VERY SMART AND ALSO SAID
CHINA SHOULD INVADE TAIWAN NEXT.
MR. PRESIDENT?
>> MY FAVORITE FOOD IS PROBABLY
BREAD.
YOU KNOW?
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY BUN.
I LIKE BUN.
BUN IS GREAT.
ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT TO
BURGER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
BEYOND BURGER.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
I WANT TO STAY RIGHT AT BURGER.
BEYOND IS NOT GOOD.
JOE BIDEN HAS GONE BEYOND BURGER
AND IT HAS NOT GONE SO WELL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
NEITHER HAS REBOOT OF FRESH
PRINCE.
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT AND I'M
LAUGHING AND I'M LAUGHING BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
I DO HEAR A DIAL TONE ON THE
OTHER END OF THAT PHONE.
SO LET'S HEAR WHAT KIND OF
PRIZES WE'RE GIVING AWAY
TONIGHT.
>> LAURA, WE'RE SENDING EVERY
RUSSIAN SOLDIER A FOX NEWS CARE
PACKAGE.
AND THAT INCLUDES A MY PILLOW, A
SIX-MONTH SUBSCRIPTION TO
LIFELOCK, AND TEN AMERICAN FLAG
CATHETERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL COURTESY OF TONIGHT'S
SPONSOR, ACORN STAIRLIFTS.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAVEN SOON.
PRACTICE GOING UP WITH ACORN
STAIRLIFTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> NOW PLEASE WELCOME AMERICA'S
FIRST COUPLE, THE REAL PRINCE
HARRY AND MEGHAN MARKLE.
DON JR. AND KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PERFORMING A DUET IN HONOR OF
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE COMING
TOGETHER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪ TELL ME SOMETHING BOY ♪
♪ DON'T YOU LOVE THAT BIG
RUSSIAN CONVOY ♪
OR DO YOU NEED MORE THIS ♪
♪ INVASION GETS ME
SO DAMN HARD
IN THE SHALLOW SHALLOW
WE'RE FAR FROM ♪
♪ THE SHALLOW NOW
I'M ON THE DEEP END
WE SHOULD TAKE UKRAINE
WAY MORE WHITE THAN BLACK ♪
>> WOW, ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO CUT THAT ONE A
LITTLE SHORT.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IS THERE A BATHROOM WITH A
MIRRORED COUNTER NEARBY?
>> YEAH, MAN, IT'S MAR-A-LAGO.
COME ON.
ALL RIGHT.
GUYS, I DO HAVE A QUICK
AANNOUNCEMENT.
IS ANYBODY DRIVING A YACHT WITH
A LICENSE PLATE NYET MEANS DA?
YOUR BOAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
TOWED BY NATO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALSO, PUTIN HAS JUST
CRIMINALIZED FREE SPEECH AND
SHUT DOWN ALL INDEPENDENT NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
>> YEAH.
SO I'M THINKING CAN WE PLEASE DO
THAT TO CNN?
>> EVERY TIME I LAUGH AN ANGEL
DIES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> NOW LET'S TAKE A QUICK BREAK.
WHEN WE COME BACK WE'LL BE
GIVING AWAY A FREE T-SHIRT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE FRONT SAYS "I'D STORM THE
CAPITOL."
AND THE BACK SAYS "THIS DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE AN ADMISSION OF
GUILT."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND PLUS WIN TICKETS TO SEE
MATT GAETZ DO A LIVE READING OF
HIS FAVORITE RUSSIAN NOVEL,
"LOLITA."
>> AND I'VE GOT SOMETHING I'D
LIKE TO SAY TO PUTIN AS WELL.
VLADIMIR, I WANT YOU TO HEAR
THIS FROM ME.
YOU ARE SMART.
YOU IS KIND.
YOU IS IMPORTANT.
AND HERE'S A LITTLE SONG FROM ME
TO YOU.
♪ MY FUNNY VALENTINE ♪
♪ SWEET COMIC VALENTINE ♪
♪ YOU MAKE ME SMILE WITH MY
HEART ♪
♪ YOUR LOOKS ARE LAUGHABLE ♪
♪ UNPHOTOGRAPHABLE ♪
♪ YET YOU'RE MY FAVORITE WORK OF
ART ♪
>> THANK YOU --
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪ IS YOUR FIGURE LESS THAN
GREEK ♪
♪ IS YOUR MOUTH A LITTLE WEAK ♪
♪ WHEN YOU OPEN TO SPEAK ♪
♪ ARE YOU SMART ♪
>> ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S MORE THAN GENEROUS --
S.
♪ DON'T CHANGE A HAIR FOR ME ♪
♪ NOT IF YOU CARE FOR ME ♪
♪ STAY LITTLE VALENTINE STAY ♪
♪ EACH DAY IS VALENTINE'S DAY ♪♪
I LOVE YOU, VLAD.
>> I KNOW.
HE LOVES YOU TOO.
AND LIVE FROM NEW YORK, IT'S
SATURDAY NIGHT!